hey everyone and thanks for tuning in uh
chances are you just saw that uh that
little 15 second introduction there if
you didn't skip the first 15 seconds or
so and as you can see by the title this
video is going to be about how to make
your own introduction for free extremely
easy now keep in mind this is just the
amateurish kind of way of doing it it's
not like um flash or anything it's not
going to be extremely customizable but
you will get results like i just showed
you right there in my last video or my
last um
my last my introduction like you just
saw so i'm gonna go through it on my
screen capturing software and show you
guys exactly how i do it and then pull
up the actual introduction itself so um
thanks for watching
all right there are a few steps to doing
this in the first place the first thing
you're going to do is go on open up any
web browser and you're going to go to
www.anymoto.com
that is the first thing
you're going to get to this animoto
website and the first thing you want to
do is sign up i created an account
already so i would just sign in
and i will take you through this whole
entire process in a second so when you
hit sign up it's just going to ask you
for your email address name
a little bit about
of birth post code et cetera then you
put in the little security code and then
you sign up so
what i'm going to do is sign in real
quick
so hold on i'll pause the video
and this is what it looks like now that
i've signed in you can see i have
several drafts in any moto of my actual
introduction video and this is my final
draft here which you saw at the
beginning of this video
so what you're going to do once you've
signed in and you know the confirmation
email and everything we're going to hit
the create video button where you can do
several things
first thing you're going to do is um get
no the first thing you're going to do
when you create a video
is select yes whether you're not going
to create a short 30 second video or a
full length video i did a 30 second
short so just click on that
first thing i did was get images from my
computer now you can sell you saw that i
took a number of images from my webcam
and from my digital camera and that's
the images that i uploaded from my
computer you know it'll pull up the uh
the documents you can go into your
pictures and everything and upload the
video would uh
upload the pictures from your computer
videos hit the upload button i'll just
upload one a little picture i guess
one second
all right i found my pictures i'm gonna
go i'm gonna control click a few of them
and hit open
so first it'll upload all three files
make sure they're not too big uh make
sure they're not more than five
megabytes per image or they won't work
so now we have
um the pictures that we want we can
rearrange the order of the pictures
change things like that um
we can change which ones we want to drop
out and actually delete them
we can add text to videos if we want to
and we can add more and delete so once
we have the three in order that we want
we just hit continue
and yes i know it's going to be a little
short but i'll hit okay anyway
now you're going to select music again
you can select this upload from your
computer or you can select from their
collection what i did was select from
their collection because i was kind of
weary about
possible copyright infringement so what
i just did was a random electronica song
the first one a night in the dark by
john kelly
so then i hit the select button
and this is the soundtrack information
so i just hit save and continue and last
but not least this is an animator short
which means you can't go half speed or
full speed and then you choose the video
cover screen which i'm fine with this
being but you just click which one you
want to be the cover screen
next you hit continue
and type in a title
and a description
the producer name create video
this is the uh this is where the
patience part comes in all you got to do
is wait till it initializes goes through
all these steps that you see here and
finishes rendering your video when it is
done it will send you an email with the
link to your video so i'll show you what
it looks like when the video is done
guys this is what it looks like when the
video is done uploading if you haven't
already received an email it will email
you you just hit the play button
and as you can see
i'll just pause it here it actually puts
in um transitions for you now it's a
very short movie obviously but it puts
in the transitions for you and they're
pretty cool they go with the music
they'll be a little bit smoother in real
life obviously and there if i pause it
it says
a title which is the title created by
marquez brownlee etc so that's pretty
cool that it actually does that now it's
here in my video so if i hit the my
videos button in animoto projects here
it is
so
the next step to creating this as your
youtube actual introduction
is
clicking on this video going to info
i'm not going to info first you're just
going to play it so it opens up the
player
i'm going to pause it and on the bottom
here you see export to youtube that's
the first thing i did so now you'll see
and i just got an email from anymoto
saying here is your link
so
now you will see when you upload it
export it to youtube i'm just going to
go to my youtube page real quick
everyone should hit that subscribe
button subscribe button
and here is my official intro
right there
this is the actual video you have the
url up in the top box
but obviously that doesn't make the
intro to all your videos does it so the
second step i'll do a later video on
this is how to download the videos using
youtube downloader
and what i did was actually downloaded
the video and cut out the ending part
that says the whole animoto thing and i
cut that out in windows movie maker and
then i set that as a beginning in hd to
every single one of my videos
so i hope that helped you guys um that
is the way that i made my introduction
and that's hopefully the way you can
make yours if you like this tutorial or
if you have any other tutorials just go
ahead and subscribe and shoot me an idea
and i will do my best thanks for
watching peace
one last thing i have to mention that
this was also a request by a youtube
user known as younom uknome so i'll go
ahead and check out his channel it's in
the description box and um i actually
subscribe to his favorites because
they're pretty good so um yeah thanks
for watching guys and i hope this
tutorial was really helpful again shoot
me your ideas i do whatever video you
ask me whatever request you need so
thanks for watching peace